-But first, as you guys know,
every week,
we like to bring you some
uplifting, creative videos,
whether they come from
quarantine
or just stuff
around the country.
It's time for
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."
-♪ What are you doing
on Wednesday? ♪
♪ What are you
doing on Wednesday? ♪
-These are good, these are good.
The first, this family came up
with a little competition
that they like to do
during quarantine.
It's called ice shuffleboard.
-Oh!
-2 inches.
-Oh, no. No!
Oh!
-It's 11.
-11.
-Come on, mama.
Oh!
Ahh!
[ All cheering ]
-Yeah!
-Yeah, mom!
That's what I'm talking about.
That's a fun game.
I would totally play that game.
Next up, check out this baby
who got the most
awesome surprise pacifier.
Watch this.
-What would you like?
[ Laughter ]
-She's just revving up, too.
She's like...
So cute, those big, blue eyes.
Could we see that one again?
Dave, is that possible?
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God!
-I'm pretty sure
that also works on adults.
And, finally, this dog
likes to watch cars drive by
and pretend he's eating them.
Watch this guy.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah! That's a good boy.
Well, sure it's cute when he
does it, but when I do it,
I'm "ruining
the family road trip."
There you go, everybody.
That is
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."
Thank you very much.